so we've got 3y squared plus 6x to the
third and we're raising this whole thing
to the fifth power and we could clearly
use a binomial theorem or pascal's
triangle in order to find the expansion
of that but what i want to do really is
a as an exercise is to try to hone in on
just one of the terms and in particular
i want to hone in on the term that has
some coefficient times x to the sixth
y to the sixth so in this expansion some
term is going to have x to the six y to
six and i want to figure out what the
coefficient on that term is and i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to figure it out on your own
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
and you might have at first found this
to be a little bit confusing i'm only
raising it to the 5th power how do i get
x to the sixth y to the sixth but then
when you look at the actual terms of the
binomial it starts to jump out of you
okay i have a y squared term i have an x
to the third term so when i raise these
two powers i'm going to get i could have
powers higher than the fifth power
but actually think about which of these
terms has the x to the six y to the
sixth let's just look at the pattern in
in i guess the the actual expansion
without even thinking about its
coefficients and we've we've seen this
multiple times before
where you could take your first term in
your binomial and you can start it off
it's going to start off
at a
at the power we're taking the whole
binomial to and then in each term it's
going to have a lower and lower power so
let me actually just copy and paste this
so this is going to be
so copy
and
so that's first term
second term make sure i have enough
space here second term
third term
fourth term
fifth term
and
six terms is going to have six terms to
it you always have one more term than
the exponent
and then
actually before i throw the exponents on
it let's focus on the second term
so the second term actually i'll write
it like this
so the second terms times six
x to the third
let me copy and paste that
whoops
so let me copy
and paste that so we're gonna put that
there
that there
and then
over
to off your screen i have it i wrote it
over there and we'll we'll see if we
have to go there and then let's put the
exponents
so
this exponent this is going to be the
fifth power
fourth power third power second power
first power
and
zeroth power
and for the blue expression for six x to
the third is going to be the zeroth
power first power
first power second power
third power
fourth power
and then we're going to have
the fifth power right over here
and with and of course they're each
going to have coefficients in front of
them they're each going to have
coefficients in front of them so there's
going to be a coefficient in front of
this one in front of this one in front
of this one then we add them all
together but which of these terms is the
one that we're talking about has x to
the sixth y to the sixth so here we have
x if we take y squared to the fourth
that's going to be y to the eighth so
that's not it if we go here we have y
squared to the third power that's y to
the sixth and here you have x to the
third squared that's x to the sixth so
what we really want to think about is
what is the coefficient what is the
coefficient in front of this term in
front of this term going to be
essentially if you put it in this way
it's going to be the third term that we
actually care about so what is this
coefficient going to be now we have to
be clear this coefficient whatever we
put here that we can use the binomial
theorem to figure out isn't going to be
this
this thing that we have to i guess our
our actual solution to the problem that
we posed is going to be the is going to
be the product of this coefficient and
whatever other coefficients we have over
here because we're going to have 3 to
the third power 6 squared so we're going
to have to figure out what that is but
let's first just figure out what this
term looks like this term in the
expansion what this yellow part actually
is
and there's a couple of ways we could do
that we could use pascal's triangle or
we could use combinatorics if we use
combinatorics we know that the
coefficient over here
this is going to be
five choose
zero
this is going to be the coefficient
the coefficient over here is going to be
five choose one and we've seen this
multiple times you could view it as
essentially the exponent choose the or
it's you know the top the top when we
the the five is the exponent we're
raising the whole binomial to and then
when we say choose this number that's
the exponent
on the second term i guess you could say
so this would be five choose
one and this one over here
the coefficient this thing in yellow
this is going to be
five
five choose two
five choose two now what is five choose
two well that's equal to
five factorial
over two factorial
over 2 factorial
times
times 5 minus 2 factorial so let me just
put that in here
times
minus
2 factorial and this is going to be
equal to
let's see 5 factorial is 5 times 4 times
3 times 2. we could write times 1 but
that won't change the value
over
2 factorial actually let me just write
that just so we make it clear it is
times 1 there 2 factorial is 2 times 1
and then what we have right over here
this is 3 factorial so times 3 times 2
times 1.
so let's see this 3 could cancel with
that 3 that two could cancel with that
two the ones don't matter won't change
the value and then four divided by two
is two so that is just two so we're left
with five times two is equal to
ten
so that's going to be this number right
over here this is going to be a 10. now
another way we could have done it is
using pascal's triangle
we could have said okay
this is
the binomial now this is when i raise it
to the second power is 1 2 1 are the
coefficients when i raise it to the
third power the coefficients are one
three three one when i raise it to the
fourth power the coefficients are one
four
six four one and when i raise it to the
fifth power which is what the one we
care about the coefficients coefficients
are going to be 1
or sorry 10
and 1. and we know that when we go for
this is going to be the third term so
this is going to be the coefficient
right over here 1 2 3 third term so
either way we know this is 10 but now
let's try to answer our original
question what is this going to be what
are we multiplying times x to the sixth
y to the sixth and now we just have to
essentially rewrite this expression so
it's going to be
times 3 to the third power
3 to the third power times
y squared to the third power which is y
squared to the third power is y to the
sixth power
y to the sixth power
times
6 squared
so times 6 squared
times x to the third squared which
that's x to the 3 times 2 or x to the
6th
and so this is going to be equal to
let's see it's going to be 10
times
times 36
and then we have of course our x to the
sixth
and
y to the sixth so this is going to be
essentially let's see 270 times 36. so
let's see let's get a calculator out
270. i could have done it by hand but
i'll just do this for the sake of time
times 36 is 9720.
so that's the coefficient right over
here it's going to be
9720 x to the sixth y to the sixth
9720 x to the sixth y to the sixth and
we're done